[Música]
y hablamos también de salud como siempre
en directo américa de france 24 con más
romeros a la mar bienvenida ya estamos a
marte feliz mañana vamos a hablar que
durante las últimas semanas han surgido
varias sub variantes de omicron hablamos
de la pandemia de kobe 19 cuáles son
estas su variantes más pues vamos a
hacer un mapa este va a ser el objetivo
de hoy porque la verdad es que cada vez
es más confuso sin darle seguimiento a
todo esto que está sucediendo no además
con las variantes pues también ha
crecido la preocupación teniendo en
cuenta la experiencia que hemos tenido
con con o micrón así que por ahora vamos
a repasar las que están reconocidas por
la organización mundial de la salud
empezamos con ba1 que es la variante
original la primera que apareció que se
reconoció identifico de omikron ba2 en
su momento es la que generó tanta alarma
ahora mismo efectivamente ya es
predominante en todo el mundo es el 86
por ciento aproximadamente de los casos
secuenciados de comida en todo el mundo
y pues es de la mano de ba2 que se ha
crecido en los casos de kobe también en
asia y en europa ba3 se identificó muy
muy al principio de omikron la verdad es
que no ha tenido mucha relevancia
epidemiológica y ve a cuatro y ve a
cinco son las dos que ayer la
organización mundial de la salud dijo
que incluía dentro de las identificadas
pues por genoma por las secuencias de
genoma aproximadamente se acumulan unas
decenas de casos no se llega al centenar
x es una sub variante recombinante es un
poco diferente luego hablaremos de ella
también porque se trata de una mezcla de
las dos primeras de ba1 y de ba2 al ser
todas consideradas o micro no todas son
variantes de preocupación claro digamos
que omicron s como la principal y equis
se sigue siendo o micro sigue siendo
micro según la organización mundial de
la salud vale mar pero entonces estos
los linajes anunciados ayer por la oms
se pueden suponer un riesgo para toda la
población pues la verdad habla mundo
debe a cuatro y ve a cinco
específicamente que son esas dos que se
han anunciado todavía no se sabe bien
hay unas pocas docenas de casos como
decíamos identificadas en sudáfrica
botsuana reino unido y también dinamarca
entre el 10 de enero y el 30 de marzo lo
que sí sabemos es que por ahora en
ningún estos países se ha provocado
ningún tipo de oleada sobre todo en
sudáfrica que es donde más casos se han
identificado se sabe que son bastante
parecidos a la variante ba2 lo que nos
puede conferir una cierta tranquilidad
de que las inmunidades adquiridas por
estos contagios van a servir para
proteger también contra estas dos sub
variantes de estos dos linajes pero por
supuesto se tienen que todavía estudiar
qué implicaciones pueden tener lo que sí
sabemos también o podemos inferir es que
porque se está expandiendo aunque poco a
poco en sudáfrica y también a otras
partes del mundo sabemos que es una
variante que al menos se transmite con
éxito eso no significa que se transmita
peor o que sea más peligrosa estamos
hablando de b1 b2 b3 b4 hasta llegar a
la equis
porque tiene un nombre diferente esta
equis y que es esta su variante claro x
es distinta porque se trata de una
variante recombinante eso significa que
hay dos células que en una misma célula
perdón se infectó de dos variantes
distintas del comicio 9 y se mezclaron a
la hora de reproducirse ay eso es
distinto en los casos de las mutaciones
que es lo que habíamos visto con omicron
o con delta que en ese caso lo que
sucede es que de reproducirse una sola
variante o un solo linaje lo que sucede
es que hay unos ciertos errores que
provocan esas mutaciones por ser omicron
de nuevo la organización mundial de la
salud considera que x es una variante de
preocupación y además también es
importante decir que no es la única
recombinante que se han identificado
también esta x d también está x f sin
embargo esas dos pues fue una
combinación entre omicron y delta que la
famosa delta cron de la que habíamos
hablado alguna vez y de hecho la verdad
largo las redes mundial del asunto ni
siquiera reconoce x efe y xd solo se
considera una variante bajo monitoreo
que es el nivel como más bajo de
preocupación que reconoce x acumula unos
pocos miles de casos y el sistema de
salud de reino unido ofreció algunos de
los primeros datos que se tienen sobre
su transmisibilidad
inicialmente la tasa de crecimiento de
xe no fue significativamente diferente
de ba1 pero con los datos más recientes
hasta el 30 de marzo de 2022 x se ha
tenido una tasa de crecimiento del 12 6
por ciento mayor que ba2 en las últimas
tres semanas la ventaja de crecimiento
de x llego al 20 9% estas estimaciones
no han sido consistentes a medida que
han aparecido nuevos datos y todavía no
se pueden interpretar como un estimado
de la ventaja de crecimiento de la
recombinante todo un mundo no omar en
todas estas variantes y toda la pandemia
y kobe 19 pero que significa que x se si
sea más contagiosa pues parece estos
primeros datos que hablaban de un 10 por
ciento de mas transmisibilidad de
ventaja de crecimiento respecto a
omicron pero sin embargo la verdad para
mí la parte más importante de este
comunicado que estábamos escuchando es
que dice que las estimaciones no han
sido consistentes y que todavía no se
puede concluir si realmente x se tiene o
no una ventaja de crecimiento sobre
sobre la variante original de o micro en
la verdad es que también puede
aprovechar para hacer una reflexión no a
veces en esa interacción entre ciencia y
periodismo nos cuesta mucho decir que no
sabemos las cosas y la verdad es que por
ahora no lo sabemos no pasó con la
alarma de omicron que luego él se vio
que realmente había motivo de alarma
pero iniciamos pues exagerando mucho
ciertas cosas pasó con ba2 y también
pasó con delta chrome para mí es uno de
los casos más ejemplares que pues
hablamos mucho hasta le pusimos una
marca no un nombre y luego se ha visto
que a nivel epidemiológico ha sido
totalmente irrelevante bueno mar
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda
esta explicación de las variantes las
sub variantes los linajes del cómic 19
que como usted lo dijo no es fácil de
entender muchísimas gracias nos vemos
mañana con más salud aquí en directo
américa